like prisoners putting checks on a
concrete wall we like to mark the
passage of time on the show and as of
today robert molars investigation into
russia has been running for an entire
year what have we learned
Jojo Geneva has been taking close notes
from day one he's a former US Attorney
of course one of our favorite guests he
joins us tonight with a recap Joe what
do we know we know that Hillary Clinton
was illegally
exonerated we knew that a year ago we
know that there was a substantial effort
to frame the current President of the
United States with crimes by
infiltrating his campaign and then his
administration with spies that the FBI
had set upon them we have learned that
the crimes were committed by the FBI
senior members of the Department of
Justice John Brennan mr. clapper mr.
Comey and others associated with the
Democratic Party in the Donald Trump and
his associates committed no crimes
that's quite a litany so to the spying
question when the president tweeted that
one morning I'll never forget it they
spied on us from Trump Tower and I don't
think it's a single person read that who
thought well that's kind of a heavy-duty
charge can you prove it and of course he
was to ride it immediately he's insane
and as a tinfoil hat guy that's in
effect been proved
oh absolutely categorically and
unequivocally it has been proved that
the FBI in violation of all guidelines
all legislation and I believe they
committed crimes in doing so purposely
sent people into the Trump campaign to
plant false information then force that
information to be forwarded back to CIA
and then funneled to the FBI to be used
as false information in FISA
applications everybody involved in that
process who knowingly participated
committed a crime so why aren't they
being held to account as of today I
understand that a referral for criminal
prosecution has been made by mr.
Horowitz to mr. Huber who was
investigating the FISA leaks the
unmasking the leaks of the unmasking and
everything we described tonight criminal
referrals have already been made and I
suggest that mr. Brennan who loves to
make comment
about the process get himself a good
lawyer not a good writer wait
John Brennan the NBC News yes paid
consultant yes NBC News's consultant the
former director of the Central
Intelligence Agency the most partisan
hack leader of the CIA in history needs
a very very good lawyer criminal lawyer
yes criminal law oh yes he he doesn't
need a set of slip-and-fall lawyer
although he's going to slip and fall
he's going to be he's going to be in
front of a grand jury shortly well
that's news yes and it's good news
there's not a single time you've come on
where I don't feel better by the end
thank you and this is no exception the
great tree feels better today Jane feels
that that's the story and I hope that
happens he richly deserves it Thank You
Chuck you bet